[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip aujourd'hui je
reçois l'artiste plasticienne frédéric
petit dans un écran fantastique à savoir
le potager du roi à versailles frédéric
petit bonjour
merci de nous accorder du temps dans
cette journée particulière
d'installation de vos oeuvres au potager
du roi alors déjà je voudrais qu'on
explique un peu pourquoi le pourquoi du
comment il se trouve que du 2 juillet au
28 août il ya une manifestation qui
s'appelle jardins ouverts qui a lieu
dans toute l'île de france près de 200
jardins vont être ouverts au public
agrémentée par des artistes alors il y
aura soit de la danse soit du siècle de
la poésie ceux du théâtre où comme vous
des artistes plasticiens qui seront
présents et qui montreront donc leurs
oeuvres au public et ben voilà et ici
nous sommes au potager du roi c'est un
lieu qui existe depuis 1600 mhz et 583
pardon qui a été créée par jean baptiste
de la quintinie pour louis xiv et qui
aujourd'hui abrite l'école nationale
supérieure du paysage et qui eux-mêmes
gère ce lieu de 9 hectares voilà j'ai
dit ce qu'il fallait dire maintenant à
vous ma chère donc déjà merci de nous
accorder du temps dans cette journée si
particulière parce que vous êtes en
train d'installer les sculptures que
vous proposez donc au public pour cette
période estivale alors on va essayer de
vous connaître un petit peu mieux vous
avez une une carrière très riche très
variées vous avez utilisé différents
matériaux explorer différents univers
bref là on va se concentrer un peu sur
l'essentiel est d'abord vos débuts le
tissage ou ça vous intéressait déjà
personnellement et puis en 71 il s'est
passé un déclic oui en fait j'ai
découvert le tissage
presque d'une manière comment dire
incongru on pourrait bien parce que
j'étais avec une amie en vacances qui
avait des files moi j'en avais trouvé
aussi aux opus je bricolais toujours un
petit peu quand même mais elle elle
avait une notion quand même du tissage
et d'eau qu'on a on s'est prise de
passion pour ça parce qu' on
cherche en commentant les fils on a
ramassé des cageots d'orange et on
attend du no fue 100 kg d'orangés on
s'est rendu compte que c'était parfait
pour ses clés voilà
propre métier et ben sauf que évidemment
très vite c'était insuffisant et donc
effectivement c'est en explorant un peu
à l'époque on parlait pas beaucoup de
tout ça de tissage artisanal
donc c'est par hasard en allant au musée
de l'homme que j'ai vu des métiers
primitif et que j'ai compris le système
de dennis pour écarter les fils de
chênes enfin voilà ça c'était ses
protégés ni de la crise est partie de la
technique bien que après j'ai continué
d'une manière très pareil toujours très
primitive de faire des images que
j'appelais c'était des tapisseries des
petites images miniatures mais toujours
sur des métiers tout simple à clous mais
quand même avec toujours ce système qui
va changer la vie de nice pour un
quartier défile voilà ce qu'on prend oui
vous êtes une artiste plasticienne bien
sûr mais jamais je voulais le dire
thaler et puis j'ai oublié l'artiste du
fil un peu constamment sur le fil c'est
un lien qui est que l'on retrouve tout
au long de votre pause et un lien
vraiment constant effectivement le fils
d'un field fil textile dont on n'est pas
au bout de
plus de vingt ans
comme on dit on m'a donné envie quand
même d'aller voir explorer plus loin
parce que ça ça me contraignait à la
surface plane et j'avais envie de
d'explorer le volume et donc j'ai c'est
là que j'ai avec le fil de fer j'ai
commencé à faire des choses en volume et
du fil de fer du petit fils tente alors
il faut dire qu'on était toujours dans
le fil voilà du tissage vous êtes passé
à la broderie oui vous avez même fait
deux séjours en chine pour apprendre le
point là la bretonne au fil de soins oui
déjà les techniques j'imagine thématique
hier et vous et vos oeuvres sont des
miniatures ou une finesse être des
médiateurs ou des miniatures vraiment
hallucinant et de séries gt de légèreté
en maps plus grand mais en local images
elles mêmes
et on peut envoyer ses oeuvres après on
parlera de l'actualité mais ces oeuvres
là qui sont quand même très important de
nos dons et votre carrière est ce que
c'est une sorte de ligne d'horizon
réinventer oui en fait faut dire que je
les appelais les premières pièces que
j'ai fait je les appelais hobereau
chinoise parce que c'était réellement
pour moi le symbole de ce voyage que
j'avais fait de l'orient à l'occident
donc le fromage le voyage à vous avez
faim non pas encore
espace dans le temps parce qu'il ya
aussi le temps de la réalisation et qui
symbolise aussi à peu sur un temps plus
long le chemin chemin de la vie shmona
vicois voilà il a troqué à tous et tout
ça d'une manière inconsciente d'accord
ok alors maintenant revenons à nos
moutons qui sont des cocons alors vous
nous proposez trois cultures différentes
de celles et ceux qui sont après en
série chacune mais alors les cocons oui
les nids et les luttes oui alors quel
est votre matériaux donc faussée et
sculptures là alors
en majeure partie du fer à béton et donc
quand j'ai voulu fil de soie aux photos
du fils de fer au fer à béton puisque en
fait le départ le point de départ
c'était mes petits nids qui rime donc
qui faisait le lien avec quand même le
fils de soin de soi va donc ça qui m'a
permis aussi de continuer d'explorer
toutes ces toutes les bannières de
triturer le fils de lancer dans mail et
de louise et de notre lassé de l'autre
la cwa là et
et après cette envie qui était bien
réaliser parce que
cette série est très satisfaisante mais
j'avais quand même envie de d'un seul
coup de du coup de passer à une plus
grande échelle comme ce que j'avais
toujours travaillé en miniature loi
était une grande tentation est
donc je vois là je me suis je me suis
carrément non c'est parce que c'était
quand même une en une sacrée entreprise
et de travailler le fer à béton envoyées
à reconnaître de rien savoir soudé tout
ça de l'église j'ai c'est grâce à mon
sens et des puits c'est pas grand chose
c'est facile je souhaiterais balle mais
si je suis comme insuffisamment et voilà
suffisamment pour que ça tienne et donc
donc j'ai réalisé ces petites ni je les
ai réalisées entre est très grand et le
plus grand possible alors un grand effet
quelle taille qu il fût sais pas si
quand il fait un mètre dix de dire quand
même amedi de l'oms est octroyé le droit
d' le godillot géant mais c'était aussi
effectivement le besoin d'affirmer que
moi aussi je pouvais faire ça voilà
c'est vrai que quand on fait des du
textile est toujours miniature on est
très très cantonniers très camp des oui
et 502 km vous vous dites d'ailleurs
départ voilà car coop méthane
et pour prouver que en tant qu'artiste
artiste libre indépendante je
choisissais de
décimer avec mon fils de fer des oeuvres
de création pure mais avec avec le fils
mais que justement
j'étais capable aussi de passer au
volume et de faire des grandes choses et
quand les choses voilà et c'est ce qu'on
va pouvoir admirer donc cet été alors on
revient au cocon oui le cocon le nid la
hutte qui aussi sorte d'abris pour les
fournisseurs les pieds c'est une manière
de protéger les pièces les pièces et une
autre passion c'est quelque chose que
j'ai que je que je que commentaires qui
me qui nous a rien qui m'habite ouhlala
merci depuis depuis tout petit comme
beaucoup d'enfants mais que j'ai gardé
je ramassais pierre je cherche dans
maman ma cour je cherche les petits
trésors de macau j'en ai toujours se
retrouver en plus des petits fossiles
minus que je trouve des pierres percées
majeures que je gardais des tout petits
cailloux percée que je fais je fais des
colliers avec big n voilà ça va de sao
pierre plus importante dans les petites
pierres rondes que je trouve dans les
bois où vous sont dans un champ pas très
loin de chez moi et appartement j'ai
trouvé ces pierres qu'ils me font rêver
à tout à fait j'ai eu envie de leur
donner un abri et donc les ut les deux
les de les élever plus d'accord et alors
ces cocons ceni on peut pas s'empêcher
de penser à la notion de d'éclosion de
naissance des deux lieux d'évolution
avec la hutte peut-être aussi que c'est
un la hauteur de la mission veiller ici
de voilà un lien entre la terre et le
ciel aussi d'accord qui est justement
qui se rattachent à qui
on peut une référence à une série que
j'ai fait aussi qu'ils étaient des
sphères que je sus sports d'espère qui
sont faites comme des dénis fermé donc b
comme des cocos aussi dans lesquels jean
ferme des pierres donc et mais que je
suis cependant c'est une forme de cosmos
d'accueil tout ça c'est ça pourrait être
un peu phase si on peut dire entre
guillemets mais ça ne l'est pas c'est
inconsciemment c'est mon rattachement
mois
petites choses minuscules mais qui a sa
place ici sur terre et qui cherche mieux
possible à magnifier toute cette beauté
en créant en créant et alors justement
pour en revenir façon un peu plus
concrète quand on fait une installation
qu'est ce qu'on se dit alors on choisit
l'endroit on se dit qu'à lancer un jeu
formidable on en voit un espace soit
fermées soit ouvert comme un jardin ici
et on dit ça c'est comme si c'était ma
maison je vais installer ma maison à
l'accord et et et là c'est vraiment
comme ça que ça se passe je m'installe
en même temps vers la ce qui s'est passé
par exemple on a fait on a fait un
repérage on était plusieurs regardez
c'est très impressionnant c'est ce
jardin oui c'est tellement grand c'est
tellement grand retrouvez en fait j'ai
fait des photos qui après je suis restée
toute seule j'ai refait le même parcours
j'ai regardé et puis d'un seul coup il
ya des endroits qui étaient plus évident
et je me suis pas encore approprié qui
devenait quand même plus évident et
après la maison je n'ai pas paniqué mais
disons l'est sont reposés et puis petit
à petit c
des lieux comme ça ils sont épaulés à
émerger et qui se sont imposés et du
coup j'étais bah oui là là je suis chez
moi la rocaille je pense qu'il ya les
cocons que vous allez tout mettre dans
la rocaille non ça c'était prévu pas du
tout il ya donc un espace ici déjà sûr
il y aura d'autres espaces je crois que
c'est ils appellent ça le carré potager
en face du bas salat savez quoi toute
évolution aujourd'hui vous êtes en train
d'installer donc on ne va pas vous
demander de détails extrêmement rare et
partir à la recherche de deux heures
parce que c'est donc c'est pas compliqué
des cocons des nids géants et des huttes
voilà voilà alors frédéric petit un
grand merci nous avons encore du temps
grand merci pour vos belles oeuvres qui
vont un très bel écrin j'en suis sûr et
qu'on va pouvoir merci à voir tout cet
été a bien fait merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis au revoir à bientôt
il